en attendant ce sommet de vendredi
devrait marquer le point de départ
officiel de la nouve nouvelle monnaie
unique l'euro et alors que les
politiques française se querelle à son
propos on l'a encore vu la semaine
dernière à l'Assemblée nationale les
sociétés de grandes distribution comme
les centres Leclerc en font la publicité
car il voudraiit qu'à l'échéance de l'an
2000 et bien leurs clients ne soient pas
désorientés par l'affichage des nouveaux
prix reportage Sophie Jouve Jean-Marc
sursin choc au rayon fromage depuis ce
matin le BRI et
européen à tous les rayons de cette
grande surface un double étiquetage en
francs et en euros incroyable la
baguette à 034 mais attention ça vaut
toujours quand même de francs 20 à 4 ans
du passage à la monnaie européenne
Lecler nous offre un petit exercice
d'entraînement gratuit c'est bien ça
peut nous mettre en avant-garde pour
pour plus tard quoi nous tenir au
courant de de ce qu'on aura à payer quoi
en euros c'est une bonne ch surtout pour
vous les jeunes pour éviter tout ce que
nos grands-parents nos parents est ce
que nous nous aussi nous avons conu en
la période de 40 45 surtout pour éviter
cela j'ai déjà de la difficulté avec les
nouveaux francs parce que dans les
nouveaux francs et puis il faut que je
convertisse en ancien francs alors je ne
vous dis pas quand ça sera l'euro ça
sera plus dur pour moi franchement un
peu débousselé le consommateur comme le
confirme un sondage publié par
Démoscopie perte de repère conversion
approximative permettant moins de jouer
sur les prix une mini révolution
s'annonce que l'on prend ici au sérieux
et pour éviter que le client ne réduit
ses achats on veut le convaincre qu'il
ne sera pas floué les gens qui sont chez
nous a priori imagine que si on fait une
campagne c'est que on a mis des prix
très bas mais derrière cette relation de
confiance il faut faire l'apprentissage
ce prix à quoi correspond-il enfant
français est-ce qu'il est cher est-ce
qu'il est pas cher est-ce que le
l'enseigne de distribution s'engage à
arrondir au prix le plus bas quand il va
rendre la monnaie est-ce qu'il va rendre
au prix le plus bas vous voyez il y a il
y a plein d'engagements à prendre 4 ans
ne seront pas de trop pour apprendre
compter en euros et en 2002 ça risque de
bouchonner encore un peu plus aux
caisses mais quand on sait qu'un tiers
des euros en circulation passera par la
grande distribution on peut-être assuré
d'ici là d'être chouchoué et d'avoir les
poches remplies de calculett
gratuit